[音楽]
僕は自分の気持ちに従って生きてきまし
た周りから色々言われることもありますが
それで
も最後
はそういうことを聞きなでも自分が決める
と思い
ますこれから僕の反省をお話しし
ますこの仕事向いてない
よ早くやめた方がいい
よ16歳の夏の日のこと
です僕が生まれたのは58年
前父ががガンで多していた
ため母が農業
と土木作業員
を勤務し
ながら4人の子供
を育ててくれまし
た大変苦労してた母
は母ちゃんが1日働いて4000円しか
ならんのに
男ちゅうだけ
で7000円にも
なる男女
の格差が
色残る時代でし
たそんな母の背中を見ながら育った僕です
が中学生の時
にこういう高い帽子を被ったコックさんを
見てあなんてかっこいいんだ
とすぐ
にこの仕事をしようと思いました国産に
なり
たいあと先考えずですいや多分考えきら
んかったんと思い
ますなぜなら僕は肉が嫌いだったん
です肉嫌いの国産ですおかしいですよ
ねだから当時から母親からはこの子は
ちょっと本当変わっとるいつも言われて
まし
たそんな僕が5円あっ
て初めて就職したの
がロイヤルホストというレストランの1号
店
です当時今写ってますけどこの頃です16
歳7歳の頃です
そして多い日は1日で140万円ぐらいの
売上をあげてたとこなんで大変忙しいお店
でし
たく
君この仕事向いてない
よもうやめた方がいい
よ仕事を始めて半年も経たないうち
にこう言われたのがこれで3人目ですで
も全く気にしませんでし
たそれは実家を出る時に母から石の上にも
3年辛抱せねかんどこういうことを言われ
てたん
ですそのおかげもあって3年経つ頃には
少し容量も覚えてきて重要なポジションを
任せられるようになったんです
その頃には肉が好きになってまし
た
そして喫茶店えたこ焼き屋
さんそしていろんなえ飲食業を経験した後
に30歳の時に妻と2人でレストランを
オープンしました
最初は大変で
たで
もそのうちお客さんも
増え従業員も
増え絶好調だった僕
はこれがいつまで続くいつまでも続くと
思ってまし
たでも世の中そんなに甘くありません
ね自分が考えてる
ことそして言ってることが絶対だとこの時
調子のてて思ってたん
ですでもこういう時
に教病が起こりました業績は一気に1まで
落ち込みましたこの時に気づかされました
周りの方のおかげ様というやっぱりその
気持ちが大事だということです
そして周りの支えもあって10年間雇われ
天長として頑張りまし
たちょっと頑張りすぎたせもあっ
て体を
少し壊しさきっかけを
で故郷で
ある福知町に帰ってくることにしました
福知町ってこういうこあの福岡県の大体
ですねこういう真ん中ぐらいに位置するん
です
けど
そして秋だっ
た実家
を活かして里山レストランをオープンした
のが5年前
です最初はあんたなんでこなとこで店やっ
とるんね
言われてまし
たでもコロナをきっかけにこういうとこで
食事するの
も幸せやねありがとうこういう風に言わ
れるようになったん
です
そしてこういう飲食関係
で長く
お世話になったということも
あり
あと少しあの若い頃です
けどちょっとひもじい思いした経験
から子供食堂をやってみたいと思ってまし
たで
もなかなか
できなかったん
ですその
時商品ということをこのことこれですね
笑うしの件と書い
てこのことをしてすぐにやってみました
これならできるとそしたら賛同する方が
増えてきたん
です商品券と
は賛同する方がハンバーグとメッセージ
カードを購入していただいてそれを子供
たちに送り
ますハンバーグを食べた子供たちが
メッセージに返事を書いてそれがお店に
貼り出さ
れる仕組み
ですメッセージで繋がる形になって
ます皆さんのご恋で成り立って
ます大変ありがたい
ですそしてこれ
から
新しいことをやってみたいということが
あり
ますそれ
は母子家庭
問題あと後継者不足
問題秋野
問題これは日本全国ほぼ同じ悩みを抱えて
ますこれは少し変わった僕がする発想です
から
うまくいかないこともあるかと思いますで
もうまくいかないことも判断の材料として
置き換えていければと本気で思って
ます
最近葛原
さんこの仕事転職だねあなたって言われる
ことがあり
ますでもそれ
は
向いてないよ早くやめたがいいよと言われ
た仕事
ですあの時自分
の気持ちに従って本当に良かっ
たそう思い
ますそして天職が天から与えられ
た才能だとすれ
ばまずこれで幸せになってくださいという
ことだと思い
ますそして
それから周りも必ず幸せにしてくださいね
ということだと僕は勝手に思って
ます今日皆さんに出会えた
ことそして今
までたくさんの
方に出会えたこと
を心
より感謝いたし
ます
ありがとうございまし
た